Voiceover:We have two
pieces of information here.
We're told that 11 is equal to eight plus
f inverse of x minus three
and that f of three is equal to 10.
What I would like you to
try is pause the video
and figure out the value of x.
It looks a little daunting at first,
you're like wow f
inverse of x minus three.
Whenever you see something like this
at least my impulse is at
least just try to simplify
the information you have
and then see if we can make sense of it.
Here we could definitely
simplify this equation
by subtracting eight from both sides.
Just so that we have f
inverse by itself on one side.
If we subtract eight from both sides,
the left hand side 11 minus eight is three
and the right hand side is
f inverse of x minus three.
Or I could write this as
f inverse of x minus three
is equal to three.
These are essentially our
two pieces of information
once we simplify this over here.
This seems pretty interesting
because we say f of three is 10
and then we're saying f inverse
of this right over here is equal to three.
There seems to be something
interesting going on,
we could even just think
about what a function
and an inverse does.
This is the domain of the function.
Domain,
and if this is the range,
we know that the function maps
from three in the domain
to 10 in the range.
That's what the function does.
If the function does that
then the inverse function
would map from 10 in the range
to three in the domain.
This would be f inverse,
so f inverse of 10 is equal to three.
Let me write that down,
f inverse of 10 is equal to three.
What this thing right over here
is the same thing as that
thing right over here.
10 must be equal to x minus three.
We could write x minus three
is equal to 10,
add three to both sides,
x is equal to 13.